.
>>> PARIS HILTON IS BACK IN THE
NATION'S CAPITAL.
SHE SPENT THE DAY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WHERE SHE URGED LAWMAKERS
TO PASS THE STOP INSTITUTIONAL
CHILD ABUSE ACT THIS COMES TWO
YEARS AFTER HILTON SHARED HER
SPECIAL STORY OF ABUSE.
>> THE LAST SCHOOL I WENT TO
WAS -- THAT WAS THE FIRST OF THE
WORST.
THERE IS NO GETTING OUT OF
THERE.
YOU'RE SITTING ON A CHAIR,
STARING AT A WALL, ALL DAY LONG,
GETTING YELLED AT OR HIT.
I FELT LIKE A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WORKED THERE GOT OFF ON
TORTURING CHILDREN AND SEEING
THEM NAKED.
>> FOLLOWING PARIS HILTON'S
ACCUSATIONS, THE SCHOOL RELEASED
A STATEMENT SAYING PROVO CANYON
SCHOOL WAS SOLD BY ITS PREVIOUS
OWNERSHIP IN AUGUST 2000, WE
THEREFORE CANNOT COMMENT ON THE
OPERATIONS OR STUDENT EXPERIENCE
PRIOR TO THAT TIME.
WITH US NOW IS MEDIA PERSONALITY
AND BUSINESSWOMAN PARIS HILTON
TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
WE SHOULD MENTION THERE WERE SO
MANY OTHER ALLEGATIONS MADE
ABOUT THAT SCHOOL UNDER ITS
PRIOR OWNERSHIP AS WELL.
I'M HOPING YOU CAN TELL US ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT YOU'RE WORKING
ON.
WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
ABOUT IT?
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT
THERE IS SEVERE ABUSE HAPPENING
AT THESE SCHOOLS.
THERE IS 150,000 YOUTH THAT ARE
SENT TO THESE PLACES, AND
THEY'RE BEING PHYSICALLY, VERB
ALLY, EMOTIONALLY AND SEXUALLY
ABUSED AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A
STOP TO THIS.
I'M HERE TO EDUCATE LAWMAKERS
AND SENATORS ON THIS VERY
SERIOUS HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE.
>> BECAUSE WHEN THOSE KIDS ARE
IN A FACILITY LIKE THIS, WHAT
KIND OF AVENUES DO THEY HAVE IF
THEY HAVE A COMPLAINT ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE BEING TREATED?
>> THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY.
THEY'RE CUT OFF FROM THE OUTSIDE
WORLD.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO TELL
ANYONE IF THEY TRIED TO EVEN SAY
IT WITH THEIR FAMILIES ON THE
PHONE, IT HAPPENED TO MYSELF AS
WELL.
THEY WILL IMMEDIATELY HANG UP
THE PHONE, YOU'LL BE PUNISHED
AND YOU'LL HAVE YOUR PHONE
PRIVILEGES TAKEN AWAY.
SO THEY DO SCARE TACTICS.
>> AND YOU SAW PHYSICAL ABUSE
AND YOU EXPERIENCED THAT, IS
THAT RIGHT?
>> YES.
ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> SO YOU'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
THIS COURAGEOUSLY, SHARING THIS
EXPERIENCE, THIS AWFUL
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU HAD IN THE
HOPE THAT OTHER PEOPLE WON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN IN THIS
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT HOW YOU WERE
WOKEN UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT WHEN YOU WERE 16, TWO
TRANSPORTERS TAKING YOU TO THIS
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT CENTER
THAT YOUR PARENTS WANTED YOU TO
GO TO.
YOU SPOKE OF BEING IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
HOW DID THAT EXPERIENCE IMPACT
YOUR LIFE AND ALSO YOUR PARENTS'
LIVES CONSIDERING WHAT THEY
EXPECTED WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
THERE?
>> MY PARENTS HAD NO IDEA.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE SENDING
ME TO A NORMAL BOARDING SCHOOL,
THAT THESE PLACES HAVE SUCH
DECEPTIVE MARKETING AND THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK AT THESE PLACES
LIE TO THE FAMILIES, AND WHAT I
EXPERIENCED AT THESE PLACES I
WILL NEVER FORGET AND HAS
AFFECTED ME AND WILL AFFECT ME
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
THAT'S WHY I'M FIGHTING FOR
CHANGE, SO NO CHILD EVER HAS TO
SUFFER IN THE NAME OF TREATMENT.
>> YOU KNOW, PARIS, I WAS
READING ABOUT YOUR STORY, AND
YOU HAVE COME FORWARD AND I
IMAGINE IT IS DIFFICULT TO TELL.
BUT IT IS AMAZING THAT YOU'RE
TELLING IT.
YOUR STORY ACTUALLY MADE ME
THINK ABOUT BRITNEY SPEARS,
OBVIOUSLY VERY DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT I WAS
THINKING BACK TO THE '90s AND
THE 2000s, AND HOW AS A SOCIETY
WE CONSUMED YOUR STORIES, RIGHT.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE MADE SO MUCH
MONEY OFF YOU GUYS AND YOU BOTH
SUFFERED AND YOU'RE NOW TELLING
THE WORLD ABOUT THIS ABUSE THAT
YOU SAY THAT YOU'VE ENDURED.
THIS SORT OF IMPRISONMENT THAT
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO GET OUT OF.
DO YOU SEE ANY SIMILARITIES?
>> DEFINITELY.
YOU KNOW, I WENT THROUGH THAT AS
A TEENAGER AND SHE'S HAD TO
EXPERIENCE IT AS AN ADULT.
AND WE BOTH ARE SO STRONG WITH
WHAT WE WENT THROUGH, AND I'M SO
PROUD OF BOTH OF US FOR USING
OUR VOICES TO STICK UP FOR
OTHERS WHO DON'T HAVE A VOICE.
AND I'M SO PROUD TO BE HERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF SURVIVORS
THAT HAVE FLOWN OUT AND I'M
JUST -- WE REALLY JUST NEED
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THESE PLACES.
>> WELL, YOU'RE REALLY ELEVATING
THIS ISSUE AND WE'RE GOING TO